.
THANKS FOR SINGING AND FOR ALL
OF US.
[LAUGHTER]
THIS IS A STRATEGY: INSULT THE
PEOPLE YOU WANT TO REPRESENT
COMES WITH A METRIC FOR
FLORIDA'S HOTLY CONTESTED
GOVERNOR'S RACE WAS SET JUST 48
HOURS AGO.
THIS DEMOCRAT IS ALREADY WRITING
OFF NEARLY 4 MILLION REPUBLIC
AND VOTERS.
>> THOSE WHO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR SHOULD STAY WITH HIM
AND VOTE FOR HIM, AND I DON'T
WANT YOUR VOTE.
IF YOU HAVE THAT HATE IN YOUR
HEARTS, KEEP IT THERE.
I WANT THE VOTE OF THE PEOPLE OF
FLORIDA WHO CARE ABOUT OUR
STATE.
>> HE'S ON THE BATTLEFIELD OF
HEAT.
I'M ON THE BATTLEFIELD OF LOVE.
IF HE WANTS HATE, CULTURE WARS,
DIVIDING PEOPLE TO MAKE THEM
HELP PAY AT EACH OTHER, THAT'S
HIS TURF, NOT MINE.
I'M ON A DIFFERENT PLANE.
>> REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS FIRING
BACK.
>> GOVERNOR DeSANTIS: THIS IS
HIS FIFTH DECADE RUNNING FOR
OFFICE, A CHAMELEON, TYPICAL
POLITICIAN.
BUT PEOPLE SUPPORT ME BECAUSE I
KEPT THE STATE OPEN AND
PROTECTED THEIR JOBS.
INTERNALLY, CHRIS WANTED TO LOCK
DOWN PURE THAT'S NOT HATE IN
THEIR HEARTS.
THEY ARE JUST APPRECIATIVE THAT
THEY HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO IS
STANDING UP FOR THEM.
>> IN THIS ELECTION, HE'S THE
BETO O'ROURKE OF FLORIDA.
THIS NONSENSE THAT CHARLIE CHRIS
WILL WIN AGAINST DeSANTIS, TO
ME, IS NONSENSE.
DID CHARLIE CHRIS JUST HAVE A
"DEPLORABLE" MOMENT?
>> IF HE WILL WIN WITH EVERY
POLL, HE HAS TO CONVINCE THOSE
DeSANTIS VOTERS TO COME TO
HIM.
LIKE THE PIRATES REFUSING TO WIN
THE DIVISION.
"I REFUSE TO BEAT TEAMS BETTER
THAN ME -- BECAUSE WHAT'S THE
PIRATES ARE NOT GOOD.
>> THANK YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
IS A BASEBALL?
>> THAT USED TO BE GOOD.
>> AND ROBERTO CLEMENTE.
HIS APPROACH SHOULD BE THIS: "I
KNOW THAT YOU ARE VOTING FOR
RON DeSANTIS.
I CAN DO THE SAME THING YOU CAN
DO, ONLY X, Y, AND Z."
CAN DO THE SAME THING IN 2020 --
THEY DIDN'T VILIFY DONALD TRUMP,
THEY VILIFIED DONALD TRUMP
VOTERS.
THAT'S WHAT HE DID IN ONE DAY.
THE FIRST DAY HE HAD THE
NOMINATION, HE ALIENATED
TWO-THIRDS OF REPUBLICANS.
>> JUDGE, YOU HAVE RUN FOR
OFFICE.
WOULD YOU EVER SAY ANYTHING LIKE
THIS CUSTOMER >> NO, I WILL TELL
EVERYONE I WANTED THEIR VOTE.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM: YOU HAVE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SAYING WE WILL
UNIFY EVERYBODY.
HOW DO YOU UNIFY PEOPLE BY
SAYING "YOU ARE FULL OF HATE, I
DON'T WANT YOUR VOTE, KEEP IT."
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S JUST STUPID, BECAUSE HE
HAS BEEN A DEMOCRAT, AN
INDEPENDENT, AND A REPUBLICAN.
I'M NOT SURE WHO HE HATES OR
WANTS TO HATE, BUT THERE'S
ANOTHER PIECE OF THIS.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THIS RACE:
IT'S ABOUT THE NATIONAL RACE,
HIS TRYING TO CREATE A NARRATIVE
THAT RON DeSANTIS IS A HATER.
HE'S DOING THE DEMOCRAT NATIONAL
COMMITTEE'S WORK, AND THAT IN
THE END.
IT'S LIKE JENNY DURKAN FROM
SEATTLE.
WE HAD A SUMMER OF LOVE, AND IN
THE END, THIS COURSE DOESN'T
WORK.
>> DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE SWEATING
HIM ALREADY BEFORE 2024.
DO THEY HAVE REASON TO BE
CONCERNED?
>> PROBABLY, BECAUSE HE IS
POLLING HIGH -- PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T RUN.
I WOULD TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH.
I THINK HE PROBABLY WOULD ADMIT
HE HAD BEEN UP LATE THE NIGHT
BEFORE.
THINK BRIAN NAILED IT IN SAYING
THAT DEMOCRATS IN '16 AND UP
'20, WE INTENTIONALLY OR NOT
ATTACKED VOTERS.
THEY ALWAYS GET IT RIGHT, EVEN
IF THEY WON'T VOTE FOR YOU.
YOU HAVE TO GET THEM TO VOTE FOR
YOU, NOT ATTACKED THEM FOR
VOTING FOR SOMEBODY ELSE SHOULD
THINK WHEN HE PRESSED HIM ABOUT
LOVE, AND THAT HIS CAMPAIGN WILL
BE ABOUT INCLUSION, HE SHOULD
APOLOGIZE TO VOTERS.
MAYBE HE DID, BUT IF HE DIDN'T,
HE SHOULD.
"I DIDN'T MEAN IT THAT WAY, BUT
WHAT I MEANT IS THAT I WILL MAKE
FLORIDA RICHER, SAFER,
HEALTHIER, MORE SECURE WITH MY
PLAN.
>> HE SHOULD BE TALKING CRIME.
>> JESSE WATTERS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> I CALL HIM CHARLIE CHRIS B.
>> HE IS LIKE A TAN DAD.
>> HE IS.
IT WASN'T JUST THAT HE SAID THEY
HAVE THEIR HATE AND THE PARTS,
BUT HE SAID "THANK GOD FOR
JOE BIDEN."
HE SHOT HIMSELF IN THE FOOT
TWICE, AND DeSANTIS WILL WRAP
THOSE AROUND HIS BURNT FACE.
THE JUDGE NAILED IT: HE'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO WIN.
HE CUT A DEAL WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE, HAD TO RUN OUT THAT
LEFT WING ARE IN THE PRIMARY,
AND THEN HE GETS IN THERE AND
GOES SCORCHED-EARTH ON
DeSANTIS, PULLS UP A FILE ON
THE GUY AND SAYS NICE THINGS
ABOUT JOE BIDEN, PROBABLY
INVITES HIM TO FLORIDA!
THEN, HE GOES DOWN AS A KAMIKAZE
AND GETS APPOINTED SOMEPLACE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION, BUT HAS TO
RUN THAT BIG MARGIN OF AGAINST
HIM BECAUSE HE NEEDS POLITICAL
CAPITAL GOING NATIONALLY.
OUT-OF-STATE AGAINST HIM, BUT
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS WILL STILL
DO WELL.
HE'S GOT A GREAT RECORD, SHARP
TONGUE, HE'S FEARLESS.
>> IN THIS LAST YEAR, I WAS IN
FLORIDA, FROM ONE PLACE TO THE
NEXT.
THE DRIVER ASKED IF THEY THOUGHT
RON DeSANTIS WOULD RUN FOR
PRESIDENT, AND "